in your brain there's a balance when we
experience pleasure the balance tips one
way when we experience pain it tips the
other it wants to remain level or what's
called homeostasis if I do something
pleasurable like eat a piece of
chocolate I get a little tip to the side
of pleasure and my brain adapts to that
phenomenon and I imagine that is these
little gremlins hopping on the pain side
of the balance to bring it level again
but the thing about the Gremlins is they
like it on the balance so they stay on
until the balance is tipped and equal
and opposite amount to the side of pain
if I wait long enough the gremlin hops
off and balance is restored but if I
continue to consume chocolate in ever
larger amounts to overcome the tolerance
then I end up with enough Gremlins on
the pain side of my balance to fill this
whole room and I'm essentially in a
dopamine deficit state with a balance
tilted to the side of pain now I have to
keep using not to feel good but just to
feel normal